a medida que avanza la guerra es cada
vez más difícil comercial con rusa y
ucrania por el mar son pocos los barcos
que pueden acercarse a la zona de guerra
del mar negro y cuando lo hacen se
enfrentan a un gran riesgo que las
aseguradoras no quieren correr por lo
que los seguros aumentan
significativamente los costos que se
trasladan por supuesto al consumidor
final el comercio por los puertos
ucranianos se ha paralizado o
ralentizado y ha hecho que algunas
empresas dejen de prestar el servicio en
estos puertos controlados por los rusos
además varias navieras también excluyen
ahora a rusia de sus rotaciones esto por
las sanciones por parte de occidente el
tráfico del mar negro representa el 1
por ciento aproximadamente el comercio
mundial en contenedores lo que no es
mucho pero para los socios de ucrania y
rusia el impacto es enorme y por ello
entonces salvamos en este momento a
jordi espín balbona él es director de
relaciones estratégicas en el european
cyber cónsul gracias jordi por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
hagamos un balance más primero cómo
impacta al comercio mundial y los costos
de estos productos la situación
portuaria de ucrania y también de rusia
digamos también cómo impacta en la
cadena de suministros ya golpeada por lo
que vimos también el año pasado es
consecuencia de la pandemia jordi
buenos días gracias por invitarme bueno
lo importante aquí está en que aunque lo
que ustedes comentaban hace un momento
que la implicación del comercio
internacional el tráfico con rusia y con
ucrania tiene el impacto que tiene en
esto es en cuanto ha dado verdad datos
económicos pero en cuanto a datos
operacionales de volumen puede llegar al
34 % que tampoco es mucho pero sí que
tiene impactos diferentes en cuanto a
las operaciones que afectan a los barcos
que circulan es decir el mar negro está
cerrado y por lo tanto puede aislarse
pero lo que sí que es importante tener
en cuenta no es tanto el aislamiento que
puede sufrir rusia en cuanto al comercio
internacional y hablamos solamente del
comercio internacional sino del efecto
que genera en otros puntos del
transporte internacional como por
ejemplo que los barcos que sean de
bandera rosa de nacional de rosa no
pueden atracar en ningún puerto
occidental
llevan mercancía y entonces pueden no
descargarse y esto crea un problema
grave porque la carga está afectada por
dos sitios por un lado
porque no puede descargar en puertos
occidentales porque la carga no tiene
ninguna culpa que sea transportada en
barcos de propiedad que usa y por otro
lado también porque los los productos
que irían a rusia tampoco pueden ser
pagados por la devaluación del rublo por
lo tanto estos dos efectos causan una
disrupción en cuanto a la disponibilidad
de contenedores ahora jordi que otras
alternativas también se pueden tener
digamos que dentro de ucrania la
alternativa por tierra por el
ferroviario no es tan viable digamos por
estos enfrentamientos por los bombardeos
que hay actualmente pero qué más se
puede hacer para que este comercio
mundial y sobre todo los socios de
ucrania no se vean afectados
bueno realmente poco se puede hacer
incluso los tráficos que estaban
saliendo debido a la congestión
portuaria congestión marítima y los
tráficos internacionales entre europa y
asia que había un tren que en 2021 en la
línea ferroviaria llegó a transportar
alrededor de un millón un millón y medio
de contenedores evidentemente esto se ha
interrumpido y lo que están haciendo es
exportaciones vía europa y evidentemente
que circule el producto por otros sitios
pero hay poco hacer es decir el
aislamiento al que se está sometiendo
rusia es severo y la afectación no
operacional es extrema es decir los
puertos no podían operar las mercancías
no pueden circular rusia no puede pagar
las transacciones internacionales y
ucrania está siendo atacada por lo tanto
las mercancías no circulan y esto es un
problema porque la mercancía no tiene
ninguna culpa la mercancía cuando
circula por los los circuitos de
transporte internacional genera riqueza
por donde pasa la mercancía es necesaria
que tenemos que pensar que la mercancía
no solamente son cosas industriales
también son bienes para las personas
medicamentos
alimentos y no está circulando y este es
un grave problema no hay otra
metodología si no se evitan corredores
para que la mercancía circule hablábamos
de corredores humanitarios
también necesitamos mercancía corredores
para que la mercancía circule porque
para qué mercancía circule que hay
personas que la transportan por lo tanto
estas personas tienen que estar seguras
que podrán transportar el producto sin
ser atacadas y esto es un problema que
ahora mismo nos está garantizando claro
ahora jordi que se espera a mediano
plazo digamos que si se puede seguir así
por más tiempo sin que se genere un
colapso económico en materia también del
comercio marítimo del que estamos
hablando
bueno el comercio marítimo no va a
colapsar porque siempre encuentras
soluciones realmente la afectación que
hay ahora mismo con el tráfico de rusia
es poca pero sí que hay un problema
grave en cuanto a las tripulaciones por
ejemplo las tripulaciones tenemos que
pensar que un entre un 10 y un 14 por
ciento de las tripulaciones mundiales
son gente de nacionalidad rusa y
ucraniana esta gente debido al conflicto
bélico vial sería bloqueado y al cierre
del swift y del sistema bancario a rusia
no están cobrando sus sueldos entonces
es un problema que no pueden garantizar
no pueden continuar trabajando porque no
tienen sueldo y entonces esto también
afecta a para lo que está ocurriendo con
los trabajadores lo que inicialmente es
los barcos que son de origen rusos y que
no tienen un directo o un conflicto
directo con el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania ahora georgia también por último
para terminar ya nuestra conversación
quiero preguntarle el impacto que ha
tenido esta situación en nosotros o
puertos digamos ha generado atascos en
los otros puertos del mundo pues cuando
la gente pues intenta llegar atracar en
otros puertos porque están cerrados de
estos de ucrania y los de rusia pues
están con sanciones si realmente esto ha
causado no hemos detectado desde que ha
aumentado desde que ha empezado el
conflicto bélico en rusia y ucrania ha
habido un aumento de la congestión en
los puertos europeos de alrededor de un
36% un 40 por ciento de espera más
elevado del que había anteriormente por
qué porque las navieras han alterado sus
escalas han saltado puertos rusos han
cambiado también la composición de sus
barcos en cuanto a contenedores que iban
o llegaban de rusia o llevaban productos
rusos y por lo tanto esto ha generado y
preside lidad y previsibilidad y la
tensión y la imprevisión en logística y
el transporte son terribles porque
entonces generan esperas y por lo tanto
más retrasos y por lo tanto más costes
porque esto al final se deducen más
costes porque aunque las compañías de
seguros continúan cubriendo todo esto
pero generan esto a unas primas más
elevadas y las compañías marítimas para
poder operar y continuar operando aunque
sea con más retrasos esto genera más
elevado y por lo tanto genera que el
coste final que acaba pagando el
consumidor por el producto siendo
transportado será más caro porque las
compañías marítimas generan unos
recargos de riesgo de guerra y de cambio
de rutas y de cambio y salto de escalas